ce mardi à l'école maternelle paul fort
la dernière heure de course a déroulé
dans une cour de récréation une pause
exceptionnellement plus longue pour les
élèves avant de se retrouver pour
quelques minutes avec leur institutrice
respectives
c'est à partir de 16h30 que les classes
vont se vider un moment particulier pour
madame negaret la directrice 1er
septembre je serai retraité de
l'éducation nationale
j'ai fait plus de 32 ans à montigny le
bretonneux dont 26 en deux directions
d'école maternelle
donc pour moi c'est une journée
effectivement bien particulière c'est la
fin d'une passion alors à la fois de la
joie parce que effectivement
eh bien je vais partir comme les autres
en vacances et puis aussi de l'émotion
parce qu'on quitte pas un métier qu'on a
aimés comme ça sans une petite larme à
l'oeil
ça sera pour tout al heure 16h30 un
départ regretté par le corps enseignant
de l'école et les parents d'élèves
bah c'est une dernière j'en ai plein
d'émotions madame d'égarer part à la
retraite
donc voilà beaucoup beaucoup d'émotion
moi j'aime bien cette dame aimait aider
beaucoup parce que j'ai un enfant
autiste
il m'a aidé beaucoup moi
c'est une famille que j'ai accompagné
pendant plusieurs années puisque j'ai eu
tous les enfants qui sont passés dans ma
classe
donc c'est sûr que des liens journée
tisser voilà des adieux chargé en
émotions la directrice se tournent
désormais vers le programme lire et
faire lire un programme
d'alphabétisation pour les adultes
elle emporte avec elle 32 ans de
souvenirs